c'est ce genre de projet qui permet de
désenclaver des quartiers et d'augmenter
la mobilité active l'autoroute des
charis c'est une barrière physique très
difficile à traverser donc dès qu'on
s'approche il y a beaucoup de voitures
beaucoup de vitesse donc d'avoir une
infrastructure sécurisée dans la courbe
des neiges c'est une excellente nouvelle
cette liaison fait partie d'une liste de
53 projets de développement ou de mise à
niveau du réseau cyclable pour des
pistes ou des bandes cyclables ce qui
pourrait hériter certains automobilistes
ou en convertir d'autres à se déplacer
sur deux roues
on peut mettre des pistes partout j'ai
rien contre ça va peut-être m'inviter
justement à prendre plus le vélo coût de
l'opération 30 millions de dollars pour
l'année 1 du Plan Vélo 2023 2027 de
l'administration plante dans les
endroits où la Culture Vélo est peu
développée mais c'est un premier pas en
plateau ici on a fait un paquet de
bandes cyclables il y a 10 ans mais
aujourd'hui on est on fait plus ça comme
ça mais l'acceptabilité sociale de
projets plus robuste elle est elle est
vraiment
Saint-Michel Parc Extension est un
arrondissement mal desservi quatre
pistes cyclables y seront développés
cette année dont une qui permettra de
rouler sous l'autoroute 40 mais chez
Vélo Québec ont des plans que Jean
talent ne fasse pas partie des projets
immédiats nous on espère que ça viendra
dès l'année prochaine parce que c'est un
axe structurant qui va permettre des
déplacements SOS d'autres nouveaux axes
nord-sud viendront s'ajouter au réseau
c'est le cas d'un projet de 7 km sur
Christophe Colomb entre Gouin et
Saint-Grégoire le plus long annoncé pour
2023 et dont les travaux devraient
s'échelonner sur deux ans
autre nouveauté Bourbonnière aura
prochainement une piste bise
directionnelle côté ouest enlevant ainsi
une voie de circulation c'est des choix
qui sont faits d'avoir une visionnelle
qui soit quand même large donc c'est
plus large que ce qu'on connaît comme
Rachel et Cherrier là qui sont des
aménagements d'une autre de notre siècle
sans oublier le projet phare du Plan
Vélo 2023 2027 le nouveau rêve sur le
boulevard Henri-Bourassa dans
l'aménagement député sur une première
portion dans l'arrondissement
Saint-Laurent ici Carla Oliveira
Radio-Canada Montréal